a timely discussion to have given that a
mob sent by Don Jr and Candace Owens is
actively trying to cancel me right now
is to ask whether the so-called victims
of cancel culture
have actually been canceled
the term cancel culture is used to
describe the social phenomenon where a
person or a group is ostracized or
they're boycotted because of their
opinions or their actions when someone
considers it offensive or controversial
or whatever the case may be and the
question that I think is interesting to
consider is even in cases where there is
a cancellation alleged to have taken
place was anyone actually canceled
because in many cases those who complain
about being canceled are facing
consequences that make sense for the
behavior or statements that are in
question like for example former
president Donald Trump was banned from
several social media platforms when he
repeatedly spread false information
about the 2020 election he incited
violence which led to the storming of
the capital and on and on
it wasn't cancel culture it was Twitter
has certain terms and conditions and
thus the
blocking or Banning of trump from
Twitter was a response to Trump's
irresponsible actions but Trump is still
super wealthy he finished out his term
as president he continues to have the
bully pulpit he's running again he is
making money was he really canceled
because the terms of service on Twitter
were replied to him I would argue not
really
uh comedian Louis C.K
faced a bunch of backlash and he did
lose a few gigs after he admitted to
what I think we're now calling sexual
misconduct covers Louis CK's Behavior
was that a cancellation or was it he
admitted to something that some found
reprehensible it temporarily had an
effect but he's produced multiple quite
successful comedy specials since then is
that really a cancellation
or is it something else comedian Kevin
Hart face some backlash he lost his role
as hosting the Oscars when some
homophobic tweets resurfaced but he kept
working he's hosted other events
including
um I think the MTV Video Music Awards
the Academy Awards pre-show is that
really a cancel a cancellation or there
were briefly some consequences to
something that he did or said
Dave Chappelle comedian Dave Chappelle
faced significant criticism for some
material about trans people in his
Netflix special his career continues to
thrive he's released multiple specials
since I think he signed a pretty
lucrative deal with Netflix for multiple
more things he still gets on Rogan
regularly and he is gets the heroes
welcome whenever Rogan brings him out
was he canceled or was it there was a
period during which there were
consequences to things he said JK
Rowling the Harry Potter author she has
faced backlash and accusations of
transphobia because she made some
statements about trans people on social
media she keeps releasing successful
books and adaptations the Fantastic
Beasts film series and on and on you
could say well she's big enough to be
uncancelable but then isn't that sort of
the point where like that so she wasn't
actually canceled Roseanne Barr also
comes to mind and then we'll move on to
Academia Roseanne Barr
face consequences when she made uh some
remarks on Twitter
and she later ended up back on TV with a
new show after some version of Roseanne
was canceled and now she's doing the
circuit and she's given the heroes
welcome everywhere so were they really
canceled if that's how it ends up now we
can also talk about Academia you know in
Academia it's been a little different
Stephen Pinker cognitive psychologist he
faced backlash for some of the things he
said about race and gender and he's
continued to teach he's continued to
have popular books was that really a
cancellation he was criticized widely
Jordan Peterson right I mean look he's
doing far better now than he was when he
was teaching psychology at uh University
of Toronto I believe it was there were
protests and there were all sorts of
criticisms and complaints and he was
um you know brought to testify before
Canadian Parliament and people are
saying they're canceling Jordan Peterson
he's as successful as ever
uh so when when I think of it Milo
yiannopoulos was more or less canceled
in what we might call a meaningful way
he was dropped by his publisher speaking
events were published after he made some
comments that some people said were
condoning pedophilia others said it's
not really pedophilia it's really
hemophilia but you could make the
argument that was a response to his
offensive remarks is it a cancellation
Mel Gibson I mean quite frankly deserved
it but he did get back to working even
after a Hiatus after his incident
involving a police officer are you
Jewish and the entire drunk driving uh
stop so the idea that cancel culture is
a threat to free speech and attempt to
silence dissenting voices is it
criticism is it consequence what is it I
think that that's perfectly fair to
explore right again right now the
right-wing mob is trying to cancel me by
calling my advertisers and saying don't
advertise with David because he blamed
the victims of a shooting for the
shooting which of course I didn't do
I blamed our politicians who send only
thoughts and prayers
it's a tactic that is completely fine to
say hey I don't like what was said give
a consequence in my particular case it's
being done in bad faith I think with Al
Franken it went too far uh but the vast
majority of these cancellations don't
really seem to even be cancellations
whether they're warranted or not we can
debate but are they even really
cancellations let me know what you think